the media continued to lose their minds
of her Trump's killing of soleimani
the u.s. takes protective steps to
prevent further Iranian aggression and
John Bolton signals he could testify in
the Senate impeachment trial i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
this show is brought to you by
expressive VPN your data is your
business protected and expressvpn calm
slash pen
all right well latest breaking
developments in the whole saga between
the United States and Iran which of
course was kicked into high gear last
week after Ron Ian back militias burned
the US Embassy I'm amazed how every news
story now begins with the killing of
soleimani cuz I'm so Emani the head of
the terror wing of the Iranian
government I'm just shocked really that
the media begin every single story with
so emani's killing as though nothing
happened before it as though this was
the beginning of time as the Trump spoke
and then there was light that is not the
way any of this worked even last week
what precipitated the actual killing of
soleimani
was the fact that iranian-backed
militias were attacking a US Embassy in
Baghdad and trying to burn it down and
kill people inside that is what
precipitated this entire crisis and
there have been months of such
precipitous action by the Iranians
attacks on Saudi oil facilities attacks
on shipping in the Straits of Hormuz
attacks on an American drone Iranian
militias attacking us-backed forces in
Iraq and all this has been going on not
just for months but for years like
literally for years and yet every single
story seems to begin with the killing of
soleimani as though Trump just woke up
one morning was like you know what you
know feels good you know and I'd love to
do today I'm just gonna kill a guy
I just boom right through the band none
of that happened
take Trump was actually convinced to do
this over a period of months according
to New York Times reporting by members
of his cabinet including Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo this was not
ill-thought-out
it is not as though the Trump
administration just did this on a
moment's notice in fact how could you
even come up with such a killing on a
moment's notice the answer is you don't
they must have been tracking Soleimani
for quite a long time and yet every
media story begins with Trump killing
Soleimani
why because this is supposed to lead to
the narrative that it's Trump who's the
true aggressor and that is the Democrat
media narrative today that the Trump
administration is doing unprecedented
terrible things what is the latest
unprecedented terrible thing well
apparently the Trump administration is
now blocking Iran's top diplomat from
addressing at the UN Security Council
that B Foreign Minister Mohammad Javad
Zarif Zarif came out like just a few
days ago and suggested that President
Trump ought to be assassinated that he
ought to die okay the the Iranian
government plays
eighty million dollar bounty on Trump's
head so Trump saying yeah you're not
coming here and you're not coming to US
soil
you're not going to this organization
that we pay for called the UN and you're
just gonna jabber there about how
terrible we are you can stick it you can
stick it buddy
and good for Trump now as a reef is like
wow that's a violation of international
law it's fun to watch the Iranians
suddenly realize that international law
violations are a bad thing after
literally decades of violating
international law after the worst sorts
of human rights violations ranging from
terror attacks in Lebanon to attacks on
Israel to attacks in Syria to backing
the Assad regime which is killed half a
million people to attacks in Yemen to
attacks in Iraq
suddenly the Iranians crying foul when
it comes to oh you won't let our
ambassador visit New York the Ambassador
who recently was talking up the
possibility of murdering your president
Wow violations of international law a
plenty here according to foreign policy
calm the Trump administration is
borrowing around stop diplomat from
entering the United States this week to
address the UN Security Council about
the u.s. assassination of Iran's top
military official in Baghdad violating
the terms of a 1947 headquarters
agreement requiring Washington to permit
foreign officials into the country to
conduct UN business according to three
diplomatic sources Iranian Foreign
Minister Mohammad Javad Zarif requested
a visa a few weeks ago to enter the
United States to attend a January 9th
Security Council meeting on the
importance of upholding of the UN
Charter so the meeting was about the
importance of holding the UN Charter
meanwhile he was mourning and planning
apparently for the attacks on the US
Embassy in Baghdad this is someone who
cares deeply about international law
probably we should take them super
seriously the Thursday meeting was to
provide Taran's top diplomat with his
first opportunity to directly address
the world community since US President
Donald Trump ordered the January 3rd
drone strike that killed Major General
Qasem Soleimani atop a rocky militia
leader among others I'm enjoying the way
that the press again characterized
sulemani who was a terrorist a top Iraqi
militia leader he's an Iranian
government official how exactly would he
be an Iraqi militia leader only if he
was a terrorist who is backing
non-governmental violent groups which is
the definition of a terrorist in this
context it's just wild okay but the way
that the media characterized this stuff
how could Trump
how could from do this yeah how could he
how could he block this terrible person
javad zarif from visiting the UN
I mean without javad zarif propagating
his propaganda how would we know what
propaganda he was going to use how would
we know it's just so awful it's just so
awful I mean it's the media stakes on
all this that are awful javad zarif for
his part is tweeting out about how
terrible all of this is he after
suggesting that the that the Trump
administration is a clown administration
and also suggesting that the United
States is a quote unquote rogue regime
javad zarif then tweeted out this
morning while the u.s. displays utter
contempt for the UN Charter and it's
catastrophic adventurism encourages
extremism and terror wait adventurism
they're telling me the adventurism is
trump killing your terror leader not you
guys using hundreds of billions of
dollars in order to support terrorism
around the globe against a bunch of
sovereign states and their citizens now
the real adventurism is killing a
terrorist got it he says tomorrow will
host terror on dialogue forum and
discuss ways of achieving regional
security including hormone' Hormuz peace
endeavor
hashtag hope because when I think hope I
think javad zarif and the Iranian regime
he says denying me a visa in violation
of 1947 you nhq agreement pales in
comparison to Pompey's threats to starve
Iranians threat to starve Iranians you
mean economic sanctions placed against a
foreign government anytime the informed
government wishes to adhere to the rules
of warfare and the rules of
international conflict then those
sanctions go away
that's Pompeo threatening to starve Iran
Ian's Trump's bluster about cultural
heritage a war crime
no bluster is not a war crime actually
blowing things up that are culturally
important for purposes of hurting a
culture that's a war crime threatening
to do so not so much of a war crime
hashtag economic terrorism economic
terrorism by that he means that we won't
do business with Iran and cowardly
assassination but what are they really
afraid of truth yes I'm sure that Trump
is sitting around really afraid of javad
zarif strewth alternatively they don't
wish to provide a forum for you to spew
your garbage for you to spew your
garbage it gets you more of the latest
developments
with regard to Iran in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that
when something breaks down in your car
it can be a giant pain in the rear to
find the right part and I had a
breakdown in my car just a few years
back and I remember having to go to
three separate auto parts stores before
I could actually find the part that I
needed and then even when that happened
I had to have somebody actually put it
in my car it was a giant pain in the
butt instead what you ought to be doing
if you are in any way literate with
regard to your own vehicle you should go
to Rock Auto comm it's a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
audio and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they have everything from
engine control modules and brake parts
to tail lamps motor oil even new carpet
whether it's your classic or daily
driver get everything you need in a few
easy clicks delivered directly to your
door
the rockauto.com catalog is super easy
to navigate quickly you can see all the
parts available for your vehicle and
filter by brands specifications and
prices as an I am NOT a car guy per se
but having run around to a thousand
different stores I'm also somebody who
loves the Internet in Rock Auto comics
it happened for me if you're a car
enthusiast you will love it best of all
prices at rockauto.com always reliably
load the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers we've got amazing
selection reliably low prices all the
parts your car will ever need Rock auto
calm go to rockauto.com right now see
all the parts available for your car or
truck and right Shapiro's in there how
did you hear about us box and they know
we sent you that helps us and it helps
them whenever you help our sponsors
you're helping the show go to
rockauto.com and right Shapiro's in
there how did you hear about us box okay
other stuff that happened yesterday it
was it was a very busy day surrounding
iranian developments there's this giant
screw-up really by the Trump
administration in which a US military
letter announcing that troops would be
repositioned within Iraq in advance of a
potential pullout was circulated and it
was unclear where this letter came from
who it was sent to and why it ended up
in the media some members of the media
immediately ran with this letter and
when they ran with the letter everybody
sort of assumed that the letter was real
but suddenly Trump had reversed himself
that the United States killed soleimani
and then we were immediately going to
withdraw from Iraq because the Iraqi
parliament had passed a non-binding
resolution with barely a quorum present
in order to get the United States to
pull out of rock that was never going to
happen but somehow there was this letter
that was circulating and and the media
got ahold of it and without verifying it
with the Pentagon without attempting to
locked
exactly where this came from or who it
was directed to they simply ran with it
and this caused a fair bit of heartburn
yesterday
according to Huffington Post Secretary
of Defense Marquess / disputed a US
military letter announcing the troops
would be repositioned within Iraq in
advance of a potential pullout espera
claims he didn't know whether whether
the letter came from and that it was
quote inconsistent with where we are
right now he said there's been no
decision whatsoever to leave Iraq
responding to that letter the letter was
a mistake chairman of Joint Chiefs of
Staff mark Milley told reporters the
letter was written by marine Brigadier
General William H Seeley of the 3rd and
was addressed to an Iraqi defense
official Seeley wrote quote in due
deference to the sovereignty of the
Republic of Iraq and as requested by the
Iraqi parliament and the Prime Minister
CG TF o IR will be repositioning forces
over the course of the coming days and
weeks to prepare for onward movement
that be referring to the us-led
international task force to fight the
Islamic state coalition forces are
required to take certain measures to
ensure that movement out of Iraq is
conducted in a safe and efficient manner
the letter was unsigned US officials did
confirm its authenticity and said that
it had been sent and received by the
Iraqis there was no timeline in the
letter so is unclear completely as to
what exactly this letter meant normally
in in the Middle East when no timeline
is actually locked down that means there
is no timeline present meaning that if
you say I'm gonna do X some day that
means it's never going to happen the
letter was written the day after a rocks
Parliament passed a resolution calling
on prime minister Adel Abdul Mahdi to
revoke rocks invitations a host US
troops which have helped the country
retake control over territory loss to
Isis in 2014 right now the United States
is about five thousand troops in Iraq
the non-binding resolution had the
support from Shiite lawmakers been no
support whatsoever from Sunni and
Kurdish members of parliament who
boycotted the special session and the
vote did not legally require the
withdrawal of troops because of the
parliamentary vote would have had to
trigger a meeting by the country's
cabinet and right now there is no
cabinet because they just have an acting
prime minister so what exactly was the
letter designed to do absolutely unclear
a top General suggested that this thing
was quote unquote an honest mistake he
said that this was a draft and that the
release was an honest mistake but
obviously this led to a fair bit of
heartburn in both the United States and
Iraq because the prospect of the United
States upping the ante by killing
Soleimani and then amis
pulling out of rock would have been a
really bad look and also really bad
policy meanwhile the Pentagon tamping
down on all of the silly rumors about
the United States targeting cultural
sites Marquez for the Secretary of
Defense came out he said no no we are
not going to be hitting any of these
cultural sites this is simply a bunch of
nonsense in comments to CNN and to CNN
he pushed back he said that the the
targeting of Iranian cultural sites
would violate the laws of armed conflict
and he said that he would not be
obviously moving forward with regard to
any of that in general according to the
US military manual in general acts of
hostility also may not be directed
against cultural property its immediate
surroundings or appliances in use for
its protection so all of the media
heartburn about that is simply not true
now a lot of what Iran is doing here
could backfire on them because right now
Aaron is announcing that they want to
back that they want to move away from
some of the actual requirements of the
Iran nuclear deal so they're still
holding within the deal but they're
saying that we are not going to abide by
the provisions with regard it's
restricting our creation of nuclear
weapons but this is in turn triggering
the Europeans to have to recognize that
the Iranians are actually not abiding by
the nuclear deal so according to Reuters
European parties to the 2015 around
nuclear deal could launch a dispute
resolution process this week that might
lead to renewed UN sanctions on Tehran
according to European diplomats see
there's more than one party here the
United States pulled out of the Iran
deal the Europeans did not pull out of
the Iran deal but that means that the
Europeans have still been funneling
money into Iran
but now the Iranians trying to punish
the United States for killing soleimani
say that they are going to withdraw from
certain aspects of the Iran deal well
this is causing the Europeans to be
forced to actually withdraw from their
aspects of the Iran deal which could
actually hurt the Iranians much worse
than it hurts the United States Iran
took a further step back from its
commitments to the 2015 pact with six
world powers announcing on Sunday it
would scrap limits on enriching uranium
though it said it would continue to
cooperate with the UN nuclear watchdog
Iran has criticized Britain France and
Germany for failing to salvage the pact
by shielding Tehran's economy from US
sanctions were imposed since 2018 when
Washington pulled out of the agreement
confirming an emergency meeting of the
EU s 28 foreign ministers would take
place on Friday and EU diplomats said we
must be read ready to read
to Iran's breaches of the nuclear deal
again what's amazing about all of this
is that there is this worldwide global
press and left assumption that the real
aggressors here are not the Iranians
that the Iranians are really being
victimized by sanctions from abroad this
is untrue anytime Iran does not want
sanctions upon Iran all they have to do
is stop pursuing nuclear weapons and
stop pursuing terrorism outside their
own borders that's it at that point all
the sanctions go away any time the
Iranians want to normalize they can
normalize it's amazing to watch as the
entire world community circles around
this idea I mean talk about soft bigotry
of low expectations that Iran should
simply be expected to be as terroristic
and nuclear seeking as they could
possibly want and it's the rest of the
world's job to sort of adjust to that
absolute sheer nonsense asked whether
all of this could mean triggering a
mechanism that could result in
international sanctions being reimpose
daunt a Tehran the envoy said it's
increasingly likely but not yet decided
Friday will be key Iran which has its
nuclear program is for civilian purposes
which of course is silly because they
are extraordinaire about global warming
over there and Tehran that that's not
one of their big policy priorities more
Policy Priorities like oppressing women
hanging gay people from cranes global
warming not high on the policy agenda
over there in Iran the idea they need
peaceful nuclear power in a country that
has vast stores of oil and natural gas
is obviously silly
they've already breached many of their
restrictions under the 2015 deal
intended to increase the amount of time
Tehran would need to accumulate enough
fissile material for an atomic bomb from
two to three months to about a year one
of the diplomats from Europe said the
vagueness of the Iran announcement makes
it more necessary than ever to launch
the mechanism since its whole purpose is
to resolve the differences that we have
on all of this so it turns out that
Trump may have just baited the Iranians
into forcing the EU to place more
sanctions on Iran which again would put
a sort of where we were back before the
Iran nuclear deal isolating Iran cutting
off its economic bloodlines and
therefore preventing them from spreading
terrorism across the region that doesn't
solve the nuclear problem but it
certainly puts the regime in Tehran on
more slim footing on shot of your
footing he'll get to more of this and
we'll get to the latest reports about
how Iran intends to respond to all of
this first let's talk about the
uncertainty
that is inherent in trying to predict
the futures I'm in the political
business it's very difficult to predict
what exactly is going to come next
particularly these days on your own life
it's difficult to predict what's going
to come next in fact it's really
difficult to predict your own death I
know super dark right but the fact is
you should be protected against the
possibility that something would happen
to you your family should be protected
this is why you need life insurance if
you're a responsible person and the best
way to get life insurance is to check
out my friends over at policy genius
policy genius makes finding the right
life insurance a breeze in minutes you
can compare quotes from the top insurers
and find the best price you could save
fifteen hundred dollars or more a year
by using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they can also help you find the
right home and auto insurance disability
insurance getting life insurance it's
moral obligation you want to make sure
that your family is taken care of I've
got life insurance you should get some
to go check out policy genius right now
at policy genius commie can
competitively shop for all of the best
life insurance on the market and all
that other insurance to policy genius
we're always gonna get the future wrong
you better get life insurance right okay
meanwhile the New York Times reporting
that Ayatollah Khomeini wants the
Iranian government to take direct action
against the United States well you know
likelihood this is posturing here's the
thing
one soleimani is killed the regime looks
weak now they have to look strong that
means a lot of posturing eighty million
dollar bounties on trump's head and
we're going to strike back in ways that
will make the world burn amana okay the
fact is that the Iranians are on notice
they know that if they do something
directly against American troops the
president Trump is not gonna stand for
that he is not going to sit by idly he's
not gonna pay them off he's not gonna
reenter this Iran nuclear deal and there
was a lot of talk in the lead-up to the
Soleimani killing and the burning of the
embassy in Baghdad that the Trump
administration was trying to use all
sorts of economic leverage in order to
force the Iranians back to the table to
shore up that Iran nuclear deal and
actually make it better get them back to
the table negotiate away their terrorist
use of money their ballistic missile
testing the Iranians didn't want to do
any of that stuff so instead they are
protesting out in the streets there's a
video of Ayatollah Khomeini going around
in which is openly weeping about
Soleimani dying and because they're very
emotional over
they're about the killing of a terror
leader and how many is sort of signaling
to the rest of the world that it's going
to be shock and awe according to the New
York Times in the tense hours following
the American killing of a top Iranian
military commander the country's supreme
leader Ayatollah Ali Khamenei made a
rare appearance at a meeting of the
government's National Security Council
to lay down the parameters for any
retaliation by the way this does give
the lie to the idea that elections in
Iran mean anything at all remember that
time that the Obama administration
claimed that the Iranian regime was
about to moderate and that if only we
propped up a Sun woo honey that this
would fix everything well now this has
been made clear the Ayatollah is still
run that country and Ayatollah Khomeini
just simply walks into the National
Security Council and lays it on the line
it's pretty obvious who's in charge over
there it must be a direct and
proportional attack on American interest
he said openly carried out by Iranian
forces themselves according to three
Iran IANS familiar with the meeting so
this is being leaked to the New York
Times because the idea here is that
anytime you signal strength to your own
people you're signaling me you're
willing to kill a lot of them in order
to maintain your grip on the regime
according to the New York Times it was a
startling departure for the Iranian
leadership since the establishment of
the Islamic Republic in 1979 Tehran and
almost always cloaked its attacks behind
the actions of proxies it had cultivated
around the region but in the fury
generated by the killing of the military
commander Qasem Soleimani
a close ally and personal friend of the
supreme leader via the ayatollah was
willing to cast aside those traditional
cautions yet we'll see we'll see
Color Me a bit skeptical that the
Iranians are going to go to direct war
with the United States because the first
person whose head will end up on a
platter is Ayatollah Khomeini and it's a
lot it's all fun and games when you're
asking other people to die for your
cause it's a very different thing when
you yourself are going to be put on the
mat by the United States military
meanwhile you got the Obama
administration out there still wringing
its hands what are we gonna do what's
our strategy here well you know it was a
bad strategy as it turns out giving lots
and lots of money to terrorists it turns
out that was an awful strategy from
beginning to end and one you see the
media tried to claim that Trump
ratcheted this thing up that the Iran
nuclear deal was working that everything
was hunky-dory just remember that is not
true hey in March 2016 the u.s. CENTCOM
nominee General Joseph Votel this is
Obama's nominee said that Iran had
actually become more aggressive since
the advent of
the nuclear deal in January 2016 Obama's
Secretary of State John Kerry openly
explained quote I think that some of the
money will end up in the hands of the
IRGC that be the Iranian Revolutionary
Guard Corps or other entities some of
which are labeled terrorists which is of
course exactly what happened so when you
listen to the members of the Obama
administration lamenting the the notion
that Trump might actually reestablish
deterrence recognized that it was the
Obama administration that for eight
years spent years undercutting
deterrence eight years undercutting
deterrence now if you want to go back
further in history there's a case to be
made that one of the big problems here
was the Iraq war itself because the Iraq
war created a vacuum for the Iranians to
move in that by disbanding the Iraqi
military which was Sunni in the
aftermath of the killing of Saddam
Hussein the capture of Saddam Hussein
that in the aftermath of the original
invasion that decision to disband the
military created this opening for Iran
it maximized Iran's regional power and
then the aftermath of that was Obama
attempting to appease Iran and now this
is Trump trying to put the genie back in
the bottle at least trying to create
some sense of containment in all of this
with that said the Obama
administration's policy of let's pay off
the Iranians not only was that a failure
it was a dramatic impetus for the
Iranian government to increase its
aggression so I'm not going to take
advice from members of the Obama
administration who are speaking out
about how terrible
it is that Trump is now reestablishing
deterrence one of those officials a
former Obama State Department adviser
named Nasser who is on CNN yesterday
with block of wood Chris Cuomo Vali Nasr
former State Department senior advisor
explaining that no I think that that if
Trump if Trump just keeps retaliated
what's he gonna do just keep retaliate
and the answers yes the answer is yes if
you keep hitting American interests we
are going to keep Rotella what are we
supposed to do sign a check well we're
gonna be Iran's whipping boy here the
Iranians are not locked into some kind
of a reaction when you see that kind of
passion in this treaty in Tehran the
past few days you can't say that you
tell the people okay it's all done go
home we're not going to do anything
about it and then what's the next step
for the president is gonna hit him again
and hit him again and ultimately is he
going to invade a country of 80 million
people where the capital city is about
two thousand miles and two mountain
ranges away from the closest port
he thought about what Iran would look
like a war with Iran it will make
Afghanistan and Iraq added together x to
look like child's play
hey no one is talking about worth Iran
Trump doesn't want war with Iran
nobody's talking about boots on the
ground full-scale war with Iran
Pompeyo who's about as militants on this
issue as anybody in the administration
is not talking about any of this but
this is the false choice the Obama
administration consistently presented if
you don't pay them off you have to go to
war with them no it turns out that the
United States has been low in low-level
conflicts with a wide variety of
external enemies for literally decades
no we don't we're not going to go to
full-scale war with run and the last
thing Iran wants is to go to full-scale
war with the most powerful military in
history on the face of the earth in just
a second we'll get to more media
malfeasance I mean the media are just in
the new york times particularly is just
awful but it's not just the new york
times we're gonna get to the media
coverage of this stuff they don't know
what the hell they're talking about as
per our usual arrangement on foreign
policy I'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about the
reality of college education it costs a
fortune it does not give you what you
need to get from it you have to take
time out of your busy schedule in order
to go do it and you've got a rack up
enormous amounts of that what if you
have to do any of those things and yet
you could still get the higher education
that you need well then you'd be talking
about using Ashford University it's a
new year and it's a new opportunity make
this the year you advance your career by
earning your master's degree get started
today at Ashford University a master's
degree that's right for you could
definitely enhance your resume it could
make it that somebody takes a second
look at that resume when they hire you
for a job it gives you the additional
education that you might need in order
to advance in the workforce you know
gaining new skill sets is something you
constantly need to be doing and over at
Ashford you're not gonna have to shell
out a fortune or to make this happen
it's convenient and it's flexible
Ashford University's online master's
degree programs allow you to learn at
your own pace more and more universities
are moving along the lines of online
education Ashford was their first
they'll let you take these courses one
course at a time
Ashford University six-week long courses
allow you to move one course at a time
being enrolled in one class means you
are considered a full time student
there's easy enrolment you don't require
other standardized test scores GRE GMAT
or anything to enroll at Ashford and
they're fully accredited by the W ASC
senior college and university Commission
so get ready to take advantage of new
opportunities in the new year start that
masters to
today enroll male by going to Ashford
dot edu slash Ben that is Ashford dot
edu slash Ben's start that master's
degree today Ashford II D you slash Ben
why spend money on a college that is
simply going to take and use it for
their Gender Studies Program instead go
check out Ashford zot edu slash Ben and
pay for what you're getting Ashford's
edu slash man okay so the media's
coverage of this obviously has been
absolutely egregious absolutely
egregious example so the New York Times
just gonna point this out the New York
Times is original obit of Cosima
sulemani hey said this Qasem Soleimani
master of Ron's intrigue and force dies
at 62 six hours later they posted this
obituary Sam Weiss who is the last coach
to lead the Cincinnati Bengals to the
Superbowl but who was later fined by the
National Football League for barring a
female reporter from the team's locker
room has died so just to contrast the
treatment Sam washe was a coach who
barred a female reporter from the team's
locker room that's in his obit headline
from the New York Times on Twitter Qasem
Soleimani
a master terrorist responsible for the
deaths of literally tens of thousands of
people around the Middle East mostly
Muslims his headline is Qasem Soleimani
master of iran's intrigue and force dies
at 62 I mean the New York Times is
really going bad for sulemani really
going to bat for sulemani they tweeted
out this morning the the sort of tagline
for their latest episode of the daily
which is their daily podcast on news
here's what they tweeted out quote
knowing general Soleimani was out there
made me feel safer said a student about
the commander killed in an American
drone strike he was like a security
umbrella above our country wow isn't
that moving don't you feel better
knowing the New York Times is militating
on behalf of one of the world's leading
terrorists really really nice stuff and
it isn't just that they have an article
by a person named aza demo of a knee
today a writer and analyst with the
International Crisis Group called the
day after war begins in Iran the
outpouring of grief for Qasem Soleimani
is the country's first act of
retaliation and this piece is just pure
propaganda
it's absolutely pure propaganda she says
last week an American drone strike
incinerated Iran's top general and
national war hero
Major General Qasem Soleimani along with
the senior Iraqi militia commander in
what can only
he understood as an act of war it wasn't
an act of war when sulemani you know was
like ordering strikes against Saudi oil
facilities or when he was attacking
shipping and international shipping
lanes or when he was ordering militia to
burn down the US Embassy and planning
further attacks none of that was an act
of war was an act of war when that guy
got killed and all he was really was a
national war hero according to this
columnist for The New York Times this is
just propaganda pure propaganda this
columnist says being here again makes me
feel that I an American citizen of
Iranian origin have been here so often
before the cycles of imminent war an
upheaval Iranians seemed destined to
face every three years cycles often
driven by the whims of the United States
and the increasing boldness from the
whims of the United States the who sits
around thinking that Bush Obama Trump by
the way Bush Obama and Trump all
campaign on the same promise not to get
into war in Middle East all of them did
write Barack Obama said he's gonna end
our endless war George W Bush in 2000
campaigns on the notion that he was
going to minimize America's military
presence so did Bill Clinton this has
been a consistent feature of American
foreign policy since the end of the Cold
War and then reality and fruits because
it turns out that Iran is a giant terror
state rogue regime but according to this
columnist it's just the whims of the
United States like presidents get up one
morning they're like those are Ronnie
ins I'm just gonna nail him nail him
also this is this idea that war and
upheaval is just Iranians destined to
face the war know people why don't you
look at the Iranian government as maybe
the source of the problem she says this
now feels like a civilizational
inheritance a legacy that my mother bore
before me her mother before her that I
will pass down to my children every
Iranians family's history is touched
with this past in its own way
okay the sentences that mean nothing but
attempt to boil down opposition to a
regime to opposition to Iranians
personally which is just absurd you know
how many Persians I know who are living
in the city of Los Angeles and despise
the regime despise the regime in Iran
there's a reason that thousands and
thousands of people over the years have
fled Iran
Minju Ron Ian's can't even go back when
Jewish Persians never go back because
they are afraid of oppression from the
regime obviously the american-backed
1953 coup destroyed both my grandfather
and great uncle's careers and so then in
service in the government and sent the
latter into exile hey thing that's
important to mention most of the
so-called American backs coup that was a
to mess
driven coup the American involvement in
the fifty-three coup was not the driving
force behind the 53 coup against most
debt in any case America's support for
and then eventual abandonment of the
Shah helped shape the 1979 revolution
disrupted all of our lives with a new
authorities expropriating our assets
Lansing and uncle in prison for
belonging to that educated pro-western
class that built modern Iran and saw the
revolution as its demise again this
comments now blaming the United States
for the fall of the Shah even though the
United States supported the Shah now so
everything is America's fault according
to this columnist he followed most at
death the rise of the Shah the fall of
the Shah the ayatollahs it's a yeah he's
sensing a common thread here in this New
York Times opinion column the years that
followed says this opinion columnist
only deepened the iranian-american chasm
there was the 1979 to 81 hostage crisis
at the American Embassy in Tehran which
killed nobody in the end but poisoned
relations to this day killed nobody you
know it was not really a big deal you
see it's just that the United States was
ticked off that 52 American hostages
were taken the United States scarcely
concealed its support for Iraq in the
devastating years of the iran-iraq war
and in 1988 as the war dragged to a
close
continued skirmishing resulted in the
u.s. Navy shooting down an iranian
passenger plane flying over Iran's
territorial waters killing 290 people
deeply regrettable lamented President
Ronald Reagan but honors and medals for
the naval officers um are you suggesting
that the United States was purposefully
shooting down Iranian passenger planes
that that was not an accident this is
just this is coming to wreck from the
Iranian government coffers and I'm not
saying this lady's being paid off I'm
just saying the the message comes
directly from the iranian government is
being parroted by this person over at
the new york times for decades now the
united states has often seemed driven to
hurt iran at times through
interventionist policies that were
careless and transactional and then
after 1979 with a fierce determination
out of proportion
so whatever challenged the new system
posed oh you see it's disproportionate
for the united states to oppose a
vicious brutal radical Islamic
dictatorship that declares an
apocalyptic vision of the future and
supports terrorism up to and including
the murder of American troops by the
thousands at a certain point Iran
started retaliating at a certain point
around me this is a column in The New
York Times at a certain point Iran
started retaliating you see the 1979
revolution was
with the hostage-taking of four dozen
Americans but at some point in Ron's
started to retaliate you see who's
really just the United States his
aggression in the 1980s it cultivated
regional groups and militias hostile to
Washington and encourage them to take
Westerners hostage and staged attacks
through these networks in later years
says this columnist Iran challenged
American roles in the Wars of the region
and interventions in bordering countries
by backing non-state allies that rose to
become formidable powers in their own
right that's a nice way of phrasing
supporting regional terrorist regimes
that cross borders murder government
officials and threaten foreign countries
this lifted tan Ron's gain of
asymmetrical leverage into regional
influence had probably never conceived
with achieving general Soleimani was
behind much of this strategy many
consider him responsible for the deaths
of thousands for his intervention in
salvaging Bashar al-assad's rule in
Syria but too many Iranians Iraqis Kurds
and others he was a pivotal figure in
vanquishing the Islamic state okay this
is just this is pure and said it's
propaganda this is pure unfiltered uncut
propaganda this is the crack cocaine of
propaganda you think the two Kurds he
was a pivotal figure in vanquishing the
Islamic state that the Kurds were
sitting around going you know we could
really use more of his irani and
terrorism the Kurds and the Sunni Iraqis
just boycotted a session of the Iraqi
parliament dedicated to slamming the
United States for killing so Imani
so this is just pure made-up nonsense
when she says too many Iranians Iraqis
Kurds and others I assume she doesn't
mean Sunnis as soon she doesn't mean
actual Kurds gonna hurt a lot of them
who are real really pro sulemani in
Syria for the many Syrians who endured
the industrial scale brutality of the
Assad regime the general LED what could
only be understood as an offensive force
Iran's leaders always reminded their
people at Syria the lone Arab country
that sided with Iran during the
eight-year Ron Rapp war could not be
abandoned and that without it Iran would
be vastly more vulnerable in the region
talk about a non-sequitur so hundreds of
thousands of people died because
soleimani is supporting Assad and this
columnist stake is that well at least
Assad supported Iran it is for these
maneuvers in part to provide Iran some
deterrence against relentless American
hostility that general Soleimani is
remembered so it was sulemani who's
deterring the United States not pursuing
regional aggression in every surrounding
every surrounding country
all of them no he was trying to deter
the United States which has had shall we
say a very slim force in place in the
Middle East relatively speaking to the
Iranians who have hundreds of thousands
of people in the IRGC and many thousands
of people more tens of thousands of
people in terrorist groups sponsored by
the Iranian government he'd become a
patriarch for an ambivalent country
adrift forgiven at least by the hundreds
of thousands who turned out for his
funeral for the heart excesses of the
force he commanded because he secured
the land in a time of the Islamic states
butchery scene as a man of honor and
merit among political contemporaries who
are usually neither of course he
certainly did not impress all Iranians
in this way he had detractors who did
not support his regional stratagems my
god my god this piece was published in
the New York Times this is published in
the New York Times the morning for the
general it could be said is Ron's first
act of retaliation what amounts to an
extraordinary four-day state funeral and
not one but two countries well the
morning that's happening in Iraq is
those she had militias that were
actually being paid off by the Iranians
just disgusting I remember as a child
concludes aza that Mahaney he's seen
your gender analyst with the
International Crisis Group I remember as
a child during the years of war with
Iraq my mother telling me about
relatives in Iran who gave away their
jewelry to aid the war effort this time
in the face of President Trump's tweets
threatening to attack Iran and destroy
its sites of cultural heritage I needn't
conjure the unity that comes today after
the country has gathered to mourn it is
already here I have a feeling there are
a lot of people in Iran who are not
super pissed but soleimani is dead and
don't like the regime very much we're
not gonna see them in the streets
because they will get shot it's just
unbelievable the New York Times doing
yeoman's work on behalf of the world's
worst human beings really well done New
York Times editors okay we're gonna get
to more of the media malfeasance because
it's not just random columnist for The
New York Times it is mainstream players
in the mainstream media who are making
excuses for the Iranian regime and
trying to suggest that Trump is the real
bad guy in this whole conflict we'll get
to that in one second first if you're
not already a subscriber you're really
missing out head on over to daily
wire.com slash subscribe for as little
as ten bucks a month you get our
articles had free access to all of our
live broadcasts our full show library
select bonus content our exclusive daily
wire a pretty great feature yeah
- now yet if you choose the new
all-access plan you will get that plus
the legendary leftist cheers tumblr and
our brand-new asked me anything style
discussion feature it allows you to
engage our hosts right or special guests
on a weekly basis so stop depriving
yourself today come join the fun we are
the largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
and so the media members of the United
States don't know anything about
anything and they they can't locate Iran
on a map but they are apparently the
best and brightest among us and their
coverage is just egregiously awful and
obviously slanted toward the notion that
President Trump is the aggressor here
why because if Iran is the aggressor
here that shows the Iran nuclear deal
was garbage right this is the big
problem for members of the media and
from any Democrats if Trump is not the
problem here if Iran is the problem then
that suggests that Iran was never going
to moderate and that a run was never
five minutes away from becoming Sweden
if only we released pallets of cash to
them then at no point was Iran seeking
moderation that in fact Iran was seeking
regional terrorism ballistic missile
testing and eventually nuclear
development as soon as the timetable on
the nuclear deal ended right if it turns
out that Iran was bad the government was
bad is bad and will continue to be bad
then from taking a harsh deterrent
action in order to contain them makes a
lot of sense but that would be a
complete rebuke to the Obama
administration's repeated lies for years
on end that the Iranian government was
on the verge of a cataclysmic
breakthrough that Iran was about to
change into Switzerland there were
moments away from moderating and
becoming positing and becoming a
positive regional force on behalf of
peace and so the media won't let that
happen so instead they're just going to
slant on coverage their coverage is
going to be all about how Trump is the
rail aggress here that crazy
row group you want to talk about a real
terrorist leader a real rogue leader
that is President Trump not soleimani
the terrorists he just ordered killed
know it's Trump so you have Richard
Angle who is just the worst he's at the
worst foreign policy analyst on the
American scene he's just terrible he's a
reporter for NBC and he hates Trump with
a passion that cannot be bridled here is
Richard Engel covering this situation
from Tehran and lamenting soleimani 17
that's the only way to put it like that
there was a comment that nikki Haley
made saying the Democratic leadership
was was lamenting it's only money said I
think that that is fair to say for a few
Democrats I don't think that's true for
the overall Democratic leadership it's
certainly true for some of the media
here's Richard Engel I mean the way that
he is gushingly talking about Soleimani
and the way that he is casting
aspersions at Trump for killing a terror
mastermind it's pretty astonishing stuff
now after this killing you saw people
not only going out in the streets
millions Ali was describing he was there
but throwing articles of their own
clothing up onto the coffin so that
attendance could rub it on the coffin so
that they would have some sort of
memento of an object that was close to
Qasem Soleimani 's body they turned him
into a martyr if not a saint and we're
seeing now all around the region Shiite
groups allies of Iran speaking in one
voice and that is that US troops have to
leave the region should be forced out of
the region starting with Iraq wait you
mean that their agenda is exactly the
same today as it was yesterday
to force American troops out of the
region which was always their agenda I
love it they turn him into a martyr if
not a saint
amar people rubbing cloths on his
coughing and people do this for Stalin -
okay so like let's get over in the
notion that the death of bad people is a
bad thing and that somehow this turns
people into a it turns him into a martyr
he turns it okay so either he's alive
and planting terror attacks or he's dead
and people are sad about it you can pick
one those are the two choices but
Richard Engel says this killing
backfired it totally backfired really
we're like a week out how have you it
how is it backfired you're gonna have to
explain Richard angle but he has no
explanation other than he just doesn't
like Trump very much it is backfired in
many ways it is United people behind
Iran when they were not and it is
increased calls for US troops to leave
the Middle East and specifically leave
Iran which is exactly what sulemani was
trying to do okay it's it's United
people who already agreed with Sony
money behind slowly money's agenda and
selling money supporters inside the
rockie Parliament horse yet in other
words nothing changed but according to
Richard Richard angle it's all Trump's
fault again they have to they have to
act as though something actually changed
here because nothing changed then Trump
was right and if something changed if
something if Trump stirred in a new era
then everything that happens from here
on in can be blamed on Trump if it turns
out that Trump was just reacting to
Iranian aggression consistent around the
ingression since 1979
but accelerated actually since the dawn
of the Iran nuclear deal then it turns
out a lot of this is Obama's fault in
fact a lot of this is everybody's fault
but mostly the Iranian regime's fault
and it's the media's fault for
pretending that Iran was not a threat as
soon as Obama suggested they were not a
threat Obama basically used the media
meat puppet he stuck his hand up there
behind and manipulated their mouth well
to think that Iran was no longer threat
yes I'm Richard Engel and I think around
is no longer a threat Martha Raddatz
over on Good Morning America was also
reporting from Tehran it is an amazing
thing one of the one of the things that
has to be done when you cover a
terrorist entity like the Iranian
government is very often their
restrictions put on reporters as to what
they can see and what they can hear this
is this is true going for like virtually
every rogue regime in history
hey famously the the USSR had what they
called Potemkin villages where they
would set up literally just storefronts
and then they would have people too and
people would oh wow look at all these
brand-new stores that are amazing over
in the Gaza Strip for example if you
wish to be a journalist in the Gaza
Strip you can only do a camasta you to
do and if you don't they expel you on
Iran Martha Raddatz has to put on the
Iranian head covering because nothing
says powerful independent journalism
that speaks truth to power quite like
obeying the dictates of the Iranian
regime and when I hear that well you
know that's just journalists doing what
they have to do let's say that Martha
Raddatz were visiting the Vatican and
the Pope wanted her to dress in a
particular way do you think that she
would just go ahead and do that if
you're visiting Mischa Arum in Israel
and they asked her to put on a head
covering do you think that you would do
it or probably not it turns out that the
reason that martha raddatz does this is
because the Iranian government is in
fact a tyrannical anti-woman brutal
regime but here is martha raddatz
suggesting that the real problem again
always as always is the trump
administration the crowds are massive
and emotional there are many tears here
many signs with solemn Annie's picture
on them but the message is also very
clear these people want revenge as we
made our way through the streets of
Tehran people surrounding us shouting
death to America
Kajri Friends of mr. Truong inside the
funeral service the emotion just as
powerful the Supreme Leader of Iran
weeping and praying over a coffin draped
in the Iraqi flag this is the largest
funeral in Iran since the death of the
Ayatollah Khomeini in 1989 well I mean
that that is pure you again that's the
uncut stuff man they got into the supply
because that it look at the weeping and
the gnashing of teeth and people saying
they'll have revenge on mr. Trump that
lady who said by the way that we will
have revenge on mr. Trump ooh is she she
has no rights inside Iran like none okay
and she is she running iranian foreign
policy or is it the guy who is who's
crying in front of soul amantes coffin
and who has been supporting terrorism
across the region forever The Washington
Post National Security columnist there's
a Washington Post national security
columnist who Twitter name is Sonam of
Akhil she tweeted hard to resist not
retweeting this and what exactly was it
that she was retreating it was a picture
of the Tehran crowd for Soleimani
funeral and the Trump inauguration crowd
right look more people supported
Soleimani than supported Trump and the
Washington Post National Security
columnist tweeted that out tweeted that
out know the media have no bias here
it's not that they hate from chris
matthews who look he's not an objective
journalist so you expect chris matthews
to be chris matthews he's an assassin I
get out of here I roll out in here
Harold run book sudo run book coming on
this show rally in here calf drunk I
took my son Imani heard of them
yesterday seem like a nice guy and I'm a
not a nice guy but not a terrible guy
not like Trump from the really bad guy
Amy Club a charity sitting over there
eating salad to come what'd he have to
say any cloud which I go chris matthews
go here we are in the assassination
business again I'm sorry this is a top
general we didn't he talked about he
wasn't operational he was a leader we
killed this guy a president eight states
that used to hide from assassination
responsibility this president is
bragging about is this test Pompeyo is
bragging about it is there a new
deviancy and the american culture that
we now support murder killing of
political leaders is this what we do now
and i don't think you're an assassin
anyway thank you so much for this
president is anyway thank you senator
supporting murder killing of orange
arrows like I hate when people do that
like let's say that Hillary Clinton had
like you know killed like murmured
Qaddafi and then said we Came we saw he
died but if she said that she was like
laughing all the time then I laughed too
ah ah
but Trump he killed the terror leader
and he's like an assassin he's like a
beeper please Assassin's Creed he
probably gets up and money plays
Assassin's Creed then he goes out and
he's assassinated people because he's in
this ass in macaque Sasson assassin
coming at the show Chris Matthews
brilliant brilliant analysis there
MSNBC's Chris Hayes joins also he says
we're so close and Chris Hayes is always
the guy who puts on the the faux
solemnity we're so close to the final
meltdown where this is what we're gonna
its thermonuclear war all the way down
and grabs Rachel Maddow's glasses right
off that desk puts him on and goes into
his Chris Hayes routine do it Chris
Hayes if you are feeling dread and
anxiety in this new year you are not
crazy we are on the precipice of what
many imagined as a worst-case scenario
of Donald Trump as president of the
United States for all of trumps
narcissism and pettiness and braggadocio
and ignorance thus far through sheer
luck we have avoided that absolute worst
case scenario the president essentially
plunging the country into a new military
conflagrations clash geopolitical
quagmire yes its geopolitical quagmire
before it was totally solved again
remember the media's goal here is to
defend Obama that's all this is they
don't care about Iran don't care about a
rock don't care about any of this their
goal is to defend Obama because Obama
was their guy and they're going to go
down in flames on that Titanic of his
foreign policy while carrying his drool
Cup that's what this is all about final
note final note here goes to Bernie
Sanders Bernie Sanders really summing up
what so many of on the Left think when
nikki Haley by the way says that some
Democratic presidential candidates
actually have sympathy for it so Imani
Sanders may come to mind here Bernie
Sanders said that President Trump or
during the death of Soleimani is like
Vladimir Putin killing dissidents this
guy is you know was as bad as he was an
official of the Iranian government and
you unleashed then if China does that
you know if Russia does like you know
Russia has been implicated under Putin
assassinating dissidents so once you're
in the business of assassination you
unleash some very very terrible forces
oh well it's just like as soon as you
assassinate you know a terrorist is
actually pursuing terrorist attacks
that's just like Vladimir Putin killing
people who disagree the government
exactly the same thing how do I know
this well because I had my pudding look
this morning that is one of your two
leading Democratic candidates for
president guys well done everybody okay
time for a quick thing I like and then
we'll get to a quick thing that I hate
so quick things that I like well there's
been a lot of talk about anti-semitism
in New York is pretty cool last week
there's something held called SEMA
hashas so this is a quick note to my
Orthodox Jewish friends out there see
how much Hoss the Talmud is this
voluminous set of of study texts
basically that were created in the first
millennium and they were supposed to be
a review of the admission of so quick
brief a quick primer on Jewish law so
basically there is the Torah which is
the five books of Moses and then there
is the and then there's the Tanakh which
is the more large corpus right that has
the prophets and it has the writings and
then you have the Mishnah which is the
oral law that was supposedly brought
down by Moses from Sinai and then was
handed down generation to generation
that was written down very early on in
the first millennium and then you had
the Talmud which was all the discussion
of the oral law and interpretation of
the oral law that comprises I think 23
volumes it is a very very large work and
it takes seven years to go through it
from beginning to end if you study a
page a day now a page today doesn't
sound like much but when it's in Aramaic
and its front and back and it's big
blocks of text that takes a while take
seven years well they have this um hush
Oz over at MetLife field in in New York
ninety thousand Orthodox Jews showed up
to celebrate the completion of this
study cycle so well there's a lot of
talk about anti-semitism in New York it
is cool that that many people have
participated in the study cycle ranging
from young to old pretty pretty neat
stuff by the way if you are into dha'fi
only so that they restarted the cycle
i've started doing da fiel me which is
to study one page of Tom lo today if
you're into that there's a great
resource put out by the Orthodox Union
called al Dava okay there is my very
sectional all its again that's all daft
or that's my very very
sectional thing that I like today here's
my broader thing that I like so Sports
Illustrated writers have now said
they're going to you
one of the things that I like best is
when members of the left are eaten by
the left it is it is quite delicious
Sports Illustrated staffers according to
CNN announced their intention to
unionize on Monday seeking better
workplace protections amid turmoil at
the legacy brand the union represents
about 80 staffers in print digital and
video Sports Illustrated's magazine
staffers were already part of the news
guild of New York Digital staffers were
not now both print and digital will be
included in the new union that is also
with the news guild in October Seattle
based start-up maven took ownership of
Sports Illustrated and immediately laid
off 40 staffers then they're gonna hire
200 contractors to increase their local
sports coverage to compete with outlets
like the athletic but now the union says
it's unacceptable that they were going
to fire anybody and move toward
independent contractors the unions had
quote decisions made by new management
over the last few months have put a
sighs reputation and long term health at
risk yes I'm sure that's what you care
about the Union you could just by the
way go get your own funding and start
your own magazine but know what you
really want is to drive Sports
Illustrated into the dust in order to
maintain the employment of people who
are not earning their keep two dozen
employees who lost their jobs women or
people of color who cares who cares not
about people being unemployed that's bad
but about like is it worse if it's a
black guy than a white guy who is now
unemployed writing for Sports
Illustrated in this in the world of
sports there's probably a better shot
that if you're a minority you're gonna
latch on more easily somewhere else than
if you are just a white guy who is
running for your local sports
publication
moreover mavens directors directive to
launch a network of team reporters on a
size platform without sufficiently
vetting or editorial oversight has
already resulted in errors that severely
undermine our credibility this is going
to go well so I am enjoying Sports
Illustrated which swung wildly to the
left and hired a bunch of lefties and
now it turns out that they're going to
unionize all their employees and kill
the profit motive for a magazine that
was already in serious trouble well done
everybody well done everybody okay you
know what I think that we we don't need
any things that I hate today there's
just too much to hate already so we will
be back here a little bit later today
with two additional hours of contents
all your updates on impeachment John
Bolton everything else plus we will have
more for you here tomorrow so stick
around for that I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director Pavel white house key
edited by Adam Sai events audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jess while alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 as the left enters day 5 of
mourning dead Iranian terrorists Qasem
Soleimani the outcry takes an explicitly
traitorous turn we examine an important
political reality you are known by the
friends you keep then the most prolific
rapists in bridge history is sentenced
to life in prison
but even amid the me to movement
virtually no one is reporting on it we
analyze a story that doesn't fit the
leftist narrative all that and more
check it out on the Michael Noel's show